[Musique]
une bronchiolite c'est une maladie
virale qui touche les bronches plus
particulièrement les bronchioles les
petites bronches des des jeunes enfants
de moins de 2 ans
[Musique]
alors les symptômes c'est un bébé qui a
le nez très encombré qui tousse qui est
grognon qui mange pas bien
qui a une respiration très très très
sifflante au contraire un signe de
gravité c'est quand il fait des pauses
respiratoires il peut avoir ce qu'on
appelle des signes de lutte c'est-à-dire
le thorax qui se creuse des choses comme
ça
donc on va voir une ce qu'on appelle une
DRP donc une désobstruction
rhinopharyngée chez le bébé donc tout
d'abord faut mettre votre bébé sur un
plan de change le bébé peut avoir
tendance à gigoter donc ça peut être
bien d'avoir par exemple là j'ai une
gigoteuse pour bien envelopper le bébé
pour pas qu'il bouge ce qui est très
important c'est de le maintenir sur le
côté pour faire la DRP donc la pipette
dans la narine supérieure la narine la
plus proche de vous vous appuyez hop ça
ressort par l'autre côté et après hop
mettez sur l'autre côté le bébé et
toujours pareil dans la narine la plus
proche de vous vous mettez le sérum
physiologique et ça ressort par l'autre
côté
et là vous avez effectué votre DRP
[Musique]
il faut la faire plusieurs fois par jour
moi je dis systématiquement avant chaque
repas et chaque coucher et puis aussi
longtemps aussi souvent que nécessaire
c'est totalement indolore mais les
enfants détestent donc les parents ça
les inquiète un peu et en fait il faut
vraiment c'était un dollar moi je donne
le conseil de le faire sur soi-même pour
pour le prouver
[Musique]